so i'm going away on a trip and a new
whole foods just opened up a young and
shepherd ant city
uh yesterday so i went because nina said
hey we need to buy some snacks for the
trip for the airplane
because i get peckish i get hungry i
want to eat and if i don't keep my food
intake there i start to get headaches
and woozy and all that so we went to
whole foods i got some snacks i want to
know if you guys have ever heard of any
of these
if not what are your favorite snacks to
bring on a trip on to the airport on the
airplane and
if not any of those what are some things
that i should be buying from whole foods
because they just opened up next to me
and i'm curious as to what you're
shopping for so here's what i bought we
have two blue diamond artisan nut fins
one is chia seeds and the other is multi
seeds i have some ginger molasses wow
cookies that are wheat and gluten free
some chocolate chip cookies that are
also wow wheat and gluten-free i know i
guess they have wow but they're wheat
and gluten-free two boxes of snackers
that are crackers that are snack i don't
know they looked interesting one is
seedlander seed lander and the other is
what's the other one oops wrong side
classic and three seed and two bags of
chips one is
way better snacks sweet chili tortilla
chips
and the other is tara mediterranean
exotic vegetable chips this bag was on
sale for four bucks it's 170 grams i'm
thinking four bucks is a sale but it's
usually like eight dollars for this tiny
bag
let me put it away look at this the
chips this is like a regular size maybe
smaller regular says bag of chips
you can see it on my hand how big this
bag is it's not big right and then the
chips go only go to here that's regular
eight dollar bag that sounds crazy to me
anyway so that's what i'm bringing with
me let me know what you would bring let
me know what i should be trying at whole
foods and let me know if any of those
are any good
believe thanks for watching guys and uh
you like this video subscribe to the
channel see you soon